did everybody watch the game fourth
quarter wait I watched the second half
here
I did not know Jason Tatum got hurt the
first [__] play dude how I felt bad
for him oh wait was that the first place
20 seconds into the game 20 something
seconds into the game he turns his ankle
badly and then I saw the replay and that
[__] looked bad but power through though
yeah I mean but he was a shell of
himself I think those are his words yeah
uh poor guy as a coach you just pull him
be like look someone's gotta step up
yeah I mean if he's if he's hurting the
team then I would pull him I think that
to be honest with you I think that like
he kind of this is like a bailout
that's true I think they lost by 20
something yeah I mean they got their
doors blown off yeah and uh I love that
this was the NBA conspiracy okay give me
some conspiracy
they had
two uh Western Conference Final Eastern
Conference Final was gonna have two
sweeps
so many so much missed out money
and so they're like hey we're gonna give
you we're gonna give Miami this win but
just extend this [__] if you
hmm
Butler was just not playing in the three
games that they lost like he was barely
playing hmm game six though
the one game six yeah and he hit they're
down two he gets fouled and a lot of
Shooters just in general when you get
fouled and you have three free throws
you don't make all three yeah he buried
all three yeah I mean it was [__] and
like nothing but net every time yeah
maybe
one it's funny is that uh when he got
fouled there was two point
one seconds left on the clock and yes
they challenged it yeah and then
obviously they reviewed the falbies I
think he reviewed everything under so it
was lost in challenge that whether or
not Jimmy Butler actually got fouled
yeah and they said two or three yeah
didn't get fouled yeah oh really and
then the ref said well he actually did
get fouled and it was a three-pointer so
we're giving him three free throws so
you're thinking boss had [__] themselves
but for whatever reason the ref said
also make the clock three seconds
instead of two they added a whole second
to the clock and it didn't really make
sense at the end of the second because
when he got no he wasn't following three
seconds he was still going in a shooting
motion like 2.6 or 2.7 or whatever which
doesn't seem like a big difference but
in this case and in this case it would
have been the game yeah so it is what it
is NBA NBA now the other argument for
the NBA being rigged is that apparently
the three refs that were ref in game
seven Miami has an o and ten record
while they're roughing wow so the
conspiracies were going around like it's
rigged they won't boss in the finals and
Boston is a bigger Market team like you
you if you're the NBA you want Boston if
you can't have the Lakers at least one
it's a legacy team you at least want
Boston they've got the whole Boston
media uh what is it called the media
operation the media I mean it's just
Boston media especially with sports it's
a fantastic machine yeah
um but what I think is a really
interesting story and I hope that the
NBA tries to exploit it is just Jimmy
Butler what a truly fascinating human
being I mean like the resilience I love
this guy I love this guy also like his
whole life story I don't I they need to
start doing this um you know they do
this like mini 24 7-esque documentaries
with the players like you got to sell
what Jimmy is who Jimmy is his life
story like how he got here he wasn't
like some highly touted Prospect yeah it
was a guy who like literally worked like
a dog to get where he is and he finally
found not only a coach But A system that
really believed in him and like built a
team around him and like shout out to
Eric spaulstra the coach of the Miami
Heat who's criminally underrated coach
yeah yeah criminally underrated
I mean like he's like guilty of his own
success I guess because you know he has
the super team yeah so I think everybody
goes oh well it's just the super team
whatever but after that it's not like
they didn't get back to the finals they
did they did get back and they've gotten
back consistently with teams it's Gabe
Vincent's respect like Caleb uh what was
the other guy's name Martin Martin like
these guys gave into wasn't even drafted
I don't think Kayla Martin got released
by the Hornets in August you're talking
about guys that we don't even know their
names they're two other quote unquote
star players are injured Tyler Harrow is
Andrew who's their six-man Victor
Oladipo who is a sensational basketball
player is injured what the [__] is going
on yeah all right guys we're gonna take
a break from this exclusive patreon clip
because I gotta tell you all about the
best dicks in the business okay yours
your dick is the best dick in the
business you might not know it because
you're not chewed up and blued up
can be same active ingredients that's
inside Viagra Cialis but this is blue
chew this is one that we rock with this
is the one that we stay married with
satisfied satisfied customers and you
can get it for free did you know that
all you gotta do is pay five dollars
shipping okay you get the best bonus of
your life five dollar shipping go to
bluetooth.com make sure you use the
promo code flagrant now let's get back
to this exclusive patreon clip join our
patreon patreon.com flagrant thank you
very much the seven undrafted players
and think about getting released from a
basketball team it's not like a football
team where there's like 50. you're not
even the 15th best player on the team
you're not even that get out of here
you're gone and then you go
you should probably be the MVP of the
series objectively like Jimmy's amazing
and really actually give it to Jimmy
because everything revolves around him
yes but he has the most played who had
more impressive statistics it's a guy
who was drafted late in the first round
or early in the second round over the
[__] it was 10 years ago and worked
himself into this or it's this guy who
got released by the Hornets
and now he's playing his ass off in this
bro there's like everybody's Ballers
though like you got to think if you you
can if you can even make it to the NBA
you're nice yes it's really so mental
where it's like the 15th person on the
bench is still nice as [__] he just
thinks of himself as the 15th person on
the bench so when it's garbage time they
look like [__] garbage I think that's
how Miami Scouts players to be honest
with you really yeah I think that like I
mean there's some crazy statistic which
is uh Pat Riley who's the president
of the Heat
I think he's been to 25
of all finals whoa or something like
that like some since he's capacity since
he's been coaching or something like
that like I forget exactly what it was
like some crazy statistic but yeah I
think he sees something in players and I
think he likes players keep in mind the
reason why Lebron is not on the heat
still
is because they refuse to treat him like
the king
yeah that's that's that's the real story
it's not like oh I need to go back to
Cleveland no no Pat Riley was like you
are a player here on this team and that
means that we're not going to cater to
you 100 like all these other teams now
granted he went he won another two rings
shout out to LeBron
but
that culture
that Dallas didn't maintain yep
Dallas had a culture that was like that
and then they said Luca is more
important than the culture and that
might work out who knows maybe one it's
also Cuban is not he's a bit of an idiot
but Cuban had it with uh with Carlisle
and um
who's the white [__] old white
guy uh no no no no no no Nelson Nelson
yeah was it Nelson there was a GM at one
time Donnie Nelson was a GM Don Nelson
was coach and I think GM as well
something like that but he got famous
Cuban yeah a little chilly in here him
and Cuban fell out Cuban fired him again
yeah and then he brought in Rick
Carlisle eventually who was good well
they had I think with
there was something going on there was
like really tiny culture there was it
but but Pat Riley was like no dude we
have a culture here and this is what it
is and I think that they target players
that they think
um you know for lack of a better
expression [__] don't get tight in
the playoffs like
Jimmy basically ran himself out of
Minnesota but he ran himself out of
Minnesota because he was like these
[__] is [__]
like I'm I'll watch these [__]
and
I think Pat saw something I mean he was
like oh this is a dog yeah and he's
physically capable of going up against
anybody yeah I mean if you look at Jimmy
like he's what six seven yeah
athletic as hell unbelievable balance
but he's a dog like the other players
feel protected he said a great thing in
the post he's like we don't have role
players on this uh we have uh we don't
have role players here we have teammates
yeah yeah it's fine fire alarm but and
he's like and when somebody goes down
for whatever reason you step in and the
hardest part is when that person comes
back
you move to a different role and that's
what we can do here yeah and that's why
we're confident that anybody goes down
that other person is ready to show up
and that's what the [__] happened yeah
you saw him not grab the Eastern
Conference that was so sick did you hear
what he said no because words he said
I'll wait till the next one yeah fire
but yeah to your point he's like [__]
focused like on some kobe [__] yeah it's
like and it's a t to me it's like
beautiful it's like wow this is a real
team this is a collection of people who
are willing to go out there and do what
needs to be done and Caleb Martin did
that he's like oh we need buckets and
you know what to what Alex was saying
earlier I was the man on every team I've
ever been on the [__] am I gonna stop
being the man for yeah Jimmy put us on
his back
time for us to alleviate a little
pressure him Martin
Ola Depot and hero come back like that
team is so deep that's crazy yeah here I
might come back for the finals no really
I think he's been cleared to resume team
activity I actually hope they don't
because that's tricky I think I think
they might be good without them yeah I
think bringing them back is going to be
the mess of the chemistry and mess with
people's heads like y'all was I was one
of the five and now I'm sitting exactly
is Haslam still in that team he is 42
years old right and he's based sometimes
you have players on a team that are
there to be one of the uh
it's like there's a coaching Authority
and it's basically you're a coach that's
playing exactly exact culture yeah it's
like and if anybody acts out of line are
you really gonna stand up yeah to a
legend you know I mean a legend will
also snuff you yeah he loves the fight
yeah he's ready to go yeah he's still
there I hope he gets a ring but it looks
like they have a good team culture like
stemming from the stars that are like
leading and being like yo we all got to
step up you know what it reminds me of
San Antonio Spurs yeah a little bit
Spurs East like pop of issues to scream
on Tim Duncan and that's arguably one of
the greatest players who've ever played
the game and Tonkin Duncan let that [__]
happen yeah so all the other players
were like
all right well where the [__] am I yeah
yeah I ain't gonna talk [__] this is one
of the greatest players ever he used to
basically say we Scout when we draft a
player we need to make sure he needs
he's able to laugh at himself he can
take it and yell that these are like
personality traits we look for and if
you don't have them we won't draft you
no yeah who said that yeah smart
um there's a quote from Butler a couple
like during the bubble he said something
about Heath culture and he said if you
don't love basketball
you will end up hating basketball if
you're here we're gonna work you to
death we're going to drill this to death
if you don't love this game like love it
yeah you're gonna [__] hate it
because that's all we do here you know
who who's really impressed me in this
series is Bam adebayo he's a beast
specific
plays usually a guy who's that size
cannot like distribute the ball like you
see it with Joker
with yogic yeah with yogurt but he's
he's just he's so proficient at passing
but like bam will be at the top of the
key Draymond could do this but
draymond's a little smaller you see him
as a guy who's be able to pass right as
his size but bam looks like a kind of
traditional big you're like I don't know
if I want you handling the ball at the
top of the [__] key
he's passing to like he's leading guys
that are cutting back door point guards
[__] those passes up yeah a big
uh supposedly clumsy big I don't think
he is dead that puts you in a crazy
Advantage when you think about it
because now you have your quickest guys
yeah who are threats from three so
you've got to run out there to guard
them
and and it just yeah there's a bunch of
guys on this team that really step the
[__] up man I want the heat to win I'm a
Nick fan we grew up hating it I know
yeah and I find myself rooting for the
heat but it's funny it's like you hate
our Boston I'm still going heat oh yeah
yeah I found myself liking them more
when hero went out because I was like
man they have no reason to be winning
right now I really I think I didn't like
them before just because they beat the
Mavs 1006 and I was so salty about it
but then when he went down and they kept
winning I was like [__] man you have to
love these guys I still think I want
Joker to get the ring for the Nuggets
because then he'll get some appreciation
yeah and I watched it I watched the
whole MVP like you know people were
saying you know uh he got the MVPs
because he was white which I do think
happens if you're a white exciting
player like I think white kids wanted to
be Steve Nash right they wanted to play
like Steve Nash so he got an MVP over
Kobe in check that shouldn't happen no
white kid is like man I dream of being
playing ball like jokic like Nicola
jokic yeah so I think that [__]
is the MVP and he's not appreciated and
what if you watch that Laker series he
ain't even play great and he's still
[__] dismantling what is he doing I
haven't watched it it's just total
control of the game from what and you
understand basketball at a different
level than me I think but like I watch
him the passing is insane the calmness
is insane there'll be six seconds left
on a shot clock and he's just working
just in the post just working not above
me you can make a pass with two seconds
left the guy just needs one second to
shoot so there's no he's never flustered
amazing shooter every skill you possibly
have as a player he has in a seven foot
body
who do you guys have yeah what's your
prediction I think I got the Nuggets I
don't think a lot of teams think sweep I
think it'll probably be six because the
heat are just tough but I think nuggets
yeah it's so hard to it's so hard to bet
against Jimmy man like the other factor
is they're going to be Ruskin game one
and if there's a game to steal they can
set the culture or the set the tempo
it's that one they've just got a lot of
I mean the nuggets have a lot of people
to go to yeah we have a lot of guys who
could score they're deep their team is
so well built yeah Jamal Murray is is
kid he's a superstar and the only reason
they did they didn't compete last year
and maybe the year before is because he
tore his ACL towards ACL before the
playoffs two years ago and then last
year it was still out so we slept on
them yeah this guy's a star man yeah
he's stud can you say Denver in Denver I
got to go with the heat man just I I
really want them to win so yeah I want
the heat one yeah yeah I want to eat the
win but I think it's gonna be like
Denver in five yeah I think a lot of
people are saying can't really stop
jokes and that's why I remember saying
you during the Laker series because game
one I remember you were like man I don't
know the Lakers made it close and they
didn't even play great and I was like
dude jokic is just different like that's
ad if he played well the Lakers won but
he was always kind of up and down yeah
and when he played well it was insane
jokic is that every game do you put you
obviously probably have to put M on
jokic but do you put Jimmy on Jamal
Murray I think you have to that is one
thing too and Jimmy will relish that
yeah not a lot of superstars will love
guarding the other team's best player of
the whole game I think Jimmy will yeah
so that can I'm really concerned about
yoga I think if you can neutralize Jamal
yeah I could help
make jokic beat you by himself yeah you
know what I mean like he can that's the
tricky thing
he can't yeah you're right he also had a
great quote and this is just like so
simple I guess but like you know he's a
great passer yeah and they said do you
like and LeBrons is a similar thing but
do you like making a great pass or
making a great shot he goes like making
a great pass he said why he goes well
when you make a great shot you make one
person happy when you make a great pass
you make two people at it's so simple
yeah very communist yeah